à à
anh
alo alo
alo chào các bạn
Ờ Ờ
hôm nay chưa thấy bạn ở bình luận chào
anh ra là thấy hơi trống trống không
biết các bạn đã ổn chưa ạ
xe
tải alto miễn phải trả lại rất được
thằng bạn nó ạ
Nghe nhạc sống ca kiểm tra à
ừ ừ
ừ ừ thì các bạn cũng biết key code các
thứ thôi Có rồi nên mệt phết I
thì các bạn này rồi phết làm thứ thứ
trong rất chuyên nghiệp
ừ ừ
à à
hỗ trợ kinh tế Mình tranh thủ chấm bài
các bạn nữa
đưa tạm thời ông sớm thì cũng chưa biết
chia sẻ cái gì Các bạn lắm
anh tâm sự tâm sự thì gần đây mình nha ở
nhà suốt chán Có chẳng có cái gì mới tâm
sự
anh tâm sự Bây giờ chắc là chị Liên quan
việc rồi Dạo này thì cũng hơi bị lừa
cũng bắt đầu bị lừa
lười theo kiểu là do
công việc ở trên công ty thì
Ừ ừ Thực ra nó vẫn thế nhưng mà có vài
cái
khó khăn mà mình kiểu
Anh bình thường Mọi khi thì mình sẽ ngồi
trên công ty mình có tập trung giải
quyết là nhàng dễ bị sau sao nhãng hơn
thì ra là cậu làm cái đấy nó bị mất thời
gian hơn
nhưng mà mình nghĩ mà về cái
số hiệu hiệu suất đồ
kiểu dạng là Ừ lúc thì mình có thể làm
cầy
112 cái tes là một hai cái kiểu việc đi
công việc đi chỉ trong vòng một ngày làm
hết lúc ở nhà
từ lúc lúc mà mua khi mình máu lên mình
cậy thì làm ở trên công ty lại bị Hơi bị
thiếu thời gian tiểu
Cho nên công ty mình ngại cái vụ mọi
người về hết rồi một mình mình ngồi đấy
nó buồn hãy cờ thế còn ngồi ở nhà không
bị thế ngồi nhà cứ thế mà làm thôi Làm
kiểu khi học xong thì thôi Làm xong thì
mình mới nghĩ trợ khác nghĩ chuyện ăn
uống luôn này giờ mày cứ mùi cầy
cho nên thành ra nhiều lúc xếp khá thích
kiểu khùng hôm trước giao một đống việc
không sao xong hết rồi
thế nhưng nhưng mà cũng có nhiều lúc là
kiểu ví dụ là hôm trước mình mình từng
nói nhớ lúc của mình bị kiểu núi ở ngạnh
không ạ khi mà các bạn sử dụng não nhiều
Ẩm Thực ra là nó bị ảnh hưởng cậu não
căng thẳng quá Trong một khoảng thời
gian thì ra là ở não các bạn chẳng Minh
Mẫn mấy mấy ngày sau
mấy lần mình bị thế nhớ chiều hôm nay
chẳng nghĩ là cái gì cả nên chỉ ngồi
chơi thôi gần như là cả với chàng một
cốc gì cả a
0,05 mê cốc nữa là cút là không vào ngồi
đọc cảm thấy mông lúc những người trò
đùa vậy ai anh sẽ có khoảng thời gian
thế thôi đúng không Mình nghĩ thế
à à
ừ ừ
ê ê
à à
cơ bản Đỗ Single có lẽ tốt hết ngoài làm
bài có người không trả lời các bạn kia
có thể à Bạn ấy chắc không bật cái chết
này nó không phải thông báo đâu không
biết bạn này thôi 20 tỷ Cậu ngồi Crow tự
động dẫn kiểm tra xem không bình luận
mới thì như thế nào không không đi bạn
đấy có vẻ lên thường xuyên để kiểm tra
cho các bạn đấy ạ
Vì
sao có đòi vào Đồ ăn vậy Tối nay á
à à
khi sex
khi sex ừ ừ
Em dậy ăn cắp file lại phone em nhé
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này thì mình không muốn bởi vì À
Đoán Muộn vẫn muốn các bạn tự code HTML
CSS cho dù nó xấu xấu thì được chứ không
quan trọng là cho đón một thì mình sẽ
đưa ra những cái kiểu yêu cầu cho cái
Đoan đấy Các bạn nhớ để bám sát vào
người yêu cầu đấy
dự đoán 1 tất cả cái đồ ăn cuối của khóa
học này à
[âm nhạc]
Ừ
nếu muốn nhìn con chó rồi cho tôi khá
đáng yêu nhưng mỗi tội nó tôi cũng khẳng
định nhiều lúc nào cũng ngu cái gì đến
thằng chủ nó nó nhìn thấy nó vẫn sủa sau
đó đi khi lại gần nó nó chắc giống chó
này thế để từng nuôi vài con nó vóc nó
đã khóc nên thành từng ô vài con này bản
chất bọn nó đều như nhau như kiểu cứ
đứng đằng xa nó nhìn thấy mình nó sủa
sau đó thì khi lại gần thì nó vẫy đuôi
bất kỳ ai nó cũng thế không phải mỗi chủ
ai kể cả người lạ vào nhà nó vẫn vẽ đuôi
đúng rồi mình nghĩ đâu có gì Bị cận
nhưng mà chó thì chuẩn là nó đánh đánh
hơi nhưng có vẻ con mày không biết đánh
hơi thế Mình mới vỏ nó bị ngu à
ừ ừ
khi sex
em dậy siạ không không bây giờ chuẩn
chuẩn là đại học hồi mà mình học thì
cũng là dạy suy đầu trước khi mà nhảy
sang lập trình nhưng mà giận dậy hẳn lập
trình được không Không bỏ qua suy nghĩ
Ừ thì thấy à vụ mình đang nói rõ cái vụ
là đồ án các bạn ngoại
thì cái đồ ăn sẽ là cái cớ để quyết định
xem bạn có phù hợp với tiếng Anh này
không Cái đồ án ở cuối khóa này mình lại
nhấn mạnh lại lần nữa nhé Thứ nhất là
Đoàn sẽ làm
với một bạn nữa có thể mình sẽ chạy
random các bạn đăng ký một cái form là
nặng số 1 xong mình sẽ chạy Loan đun để
mà khớp bạn là với bạn nào gì gì đó đối
ngoại đấy thì sau đó thì mình sẽ
cho các bạn sẽ tự liên hệ với nhau đúng
ạ để mà để mà kiểu
để mà làm cùng một cái đồ án là món lai
cũng được hôm sau hơi bị anh khó giao
tiếp một tí biết đâu mày Ông có con gái
biết đâu Người không lại anh kiểu quen
nhau trở thành bạn thân đấy
thì sợ sau đó thì mình sẽ đưa các yêu
cầu của cái đồ này như mình vừa nói qua
thì nó sẽ là không ăn cắp gia vị sau K
Nói chung cố tuần hoàn toàn không có thể
thêm gj nếu mà Mấy ông đã biết qua nhưng
mà sẽ chỉ dừng ở mức độ kiểu really có
thứ không ôm một phim quốc nào đó về ờ ờ
Thực ra thì do mình dạy pp này mình sẽ
chỉ mong các bạn cố Tùng TPP để mình sẽ
chấm
nhẹ sau đó thì nói chung là cũng sẽ
Em làm trong khoảng 23 tháng nên là cái
vụ mà Hồi trước có bạn bình luận ở trên
kênh mình là mong là hết khóa này tầm
Tết Tết âm Nhà Trực trước Tết âm hay sau
tâm đấy thì đi thực tập được thực ra là
bây giờ mới còn chưa bắt đầu làm đồ án
thì chắc à phải đến
phải đến tháng 2 tháng 3 thì may ra ba
đồ
mới mới nghĩ việc là xong được cái đùa
đấy xong đồ ăn đấy thì mới Chị biết được
về vụ là các bạn có phù hợp với những
ngày này không thôi chứ như mình nói thì
nếu mà các bạn thực sự cảm thấy ổn thì
các bạn nên học nốt cái khóa nâng ca
không phải tôi muốn câu view của mấy ông
đâu mà chẳng qua là làm học cái đấy xong
chỉ biết toàn bộ tất cả về cơ bản mà nó
ngọn các bạn muốn thực sự là
đi làm 1 phát luôn phỏng vấn một phát ăn
ngay vân vân
địa chỉ các bạn sẽ kiểu
chị sẽ cần phải cậu có kiến thức chuyên
sâu hơn một tí bởi vì kiểu gì Các bạn
nếu mà có kiến thức cơ bản thôi đi làm
thì họ cũng sẽ phải đào tạo lại mà ít
nơi đào tạo Ôi Phải khẳng định như thế
bởi vì người ta thiếu người người ta sẽ
bóc lột các bạn là một này Thứ hai là
người ta sẽ vứt cho các bạn tài liệu của
bạn tự học thế thì tại sao không dành
thời gian để ở nhà vậy mà có học nốt vân
vân
à à
cs8 ông trên loại S8 là cái gì vậy
a react thì sao anh ờ
Ừ lát nhỏ fimware hình trong ngôn ngữ gì
đó Khi mà Đúng là tôi đúng rồi gặp là
ngôn ngữ giống nhà tôi được sinh hay
nhầm hai khái niệm này lắm í
bí thư viện à Nó đưa cho làm chút chuyện
à
Ừ ok à
khi bé
này để tôi lại ngồi sát sát vào cái mic
ngồi tôi sẽ mua cái giá treo mic sao Ờ
thì
mình mình bảo là mình mình không dùng
mấy cái khẩu quyết này hay view thôi Thứ
mình chỉ cũng làm ôm gj vì tại sao rồi
vì nó là nó để viết cốt ra Swift là ngắn
hơn chứ không phải là nhảy sáng hẳn một
cái phức tạp như thế này
Ẩm Thực ra là các bạn áp dụng cũng cũng
không không thể không thể bắt các bạn
không áp dụng được nhưng mà ý mình ạ
lá cây quất cái này các bạn cố làm cơ
bản hết đi Giống nhờ phải cốc cả ra cả
hmcs các bạn ấy thay vì bút chat để các
bạn kiểu làm theo giọng cơ bản thì các
bạn sẽ thế nào cho dù các bạn có thể có
kiến thức hẳn nâng cao rồi như các bạn
thử đám cưới bạn xem bạn làm được không
Bởi vì mục đích ổ khóa học này trong da
cơ bản còn các bạn muốn thực sự là nằm
nâng cao thì các bạn nên nhảy sang bên
bác em thì nó về những cái việc à Thiết
kế poster bay này đã cả làm những tính
năng nâng cao này chứ đừng quan tâm về
việc của giao diện xấu hay là kiểu em
không dùng
fan wordsquare em không chịu được lại
không cần mấy cái điều đấy
Ý là mình cần quan trọng là cần tính
năng cũng trang web mà đúng ạ à
em còn nếu mà thực sự các bạn muốn cậu
nó màu mè muốn nó kiểu dạng mà không cần
đoán lại trang trang phản ứng nhanh xử
lý hết ở prensa Vân Vân Vân ốp với nhiều
top dẫn cả phim gốc thì hãy đợi xanh
khóa nâng cao để các bạn tỏa sáng sau
lúc đấy thì tôi chẳng giới hạn với ông
cái gì cả mấy ông dùng bất kỳ ngôn ngữ
lập trình gì vùng bất kỳ Facebook gì
thật Chị Ôm Cốt về mà vẫn chạy được đấy
Kiểu thế
xe tải miễn sao làm khi mà tôi hỏi mấy
ông mấy ông hiểu được cái cốt mà mày ôm
ôm về cho hỏi 3 câu mà không Trời được
thì nghỉ còn nếu mà ông trả lời được hết
ông hiểu hết thì ok đấy gần như ở bằng
trang web của ông rồi nó nó của không ạ
cô bạn kia hỏi về việc để tốt lên với
ghé thăm mà không hiển thị được thì chắc
à Bạn muốn đến box riêng mình Hà là nhắn
tin ở trên discord để mọi người xem qua
được
Ừ ừ thường là đợi một lúc thì nó mới
hiển thị lên cũng thể thế Ok mình xin
trả lời
những câu hỏi từ buổi trước nhé cũng khá
là ít thôi đầu tiên là ra Speed nên để ở
đâu bởi vì hôm trước có bạn để ra Speed
và trên cung sau đó thì không không nhận
bản thân thì
mình đọc thì nó là kiểu dáng bàn bản
chất là ra Swift phần nên loát khi mà cả
cái tài liệu đó comment Các bạn nhớ về
cái thật đấy à
ừ ừ
tất cả cái tài liệu HTML của mình phải
được lót xong rồi thì cái da Swift này
mới được cầm Lost thế nên là ra quyết
thường hay để cuối và kết hợp với việc
và đôi khi mình về đợi cái đó comment
pop xong đấy nghe thành ra để làm gì để
mà bản chất cái ra Swift là nó sẽ liên
quan đến tài liệu đấy
Anh đóng phải dán cái Dạ nó gần giống
như là hôm trước mình nói về cái vụ là
HM là xương sống còn ra Swift là cho nó
thêm dây thần kinh do ngồi dây cậu các
cô các thử thứ để cho cái cái cái cơ
quan đấy có thể vận động được cánh tay
đấy cánh chân đấy có thể hoạt động được
rằng ạ thì đầu tiên phải có cánh tay
mình chân xong rồi mới dán được cái chức
năng cho cái lấy cái bộ phận đấy đúng ạ
thành ra là ra squishy phải luôn đoán ở
cuối khi mà tài liệu được tải xong rồi
còn CS như mình đã nói để trên cùng bởi
vì à sẽ thì cần khai báo ngay từ đầu để
để tài liệu biết được là nó sẽ Lênin
trong khi nào nếu đơn như là thực tế nó
ấy Nói lý thuyết là như thế nhưng thực
tế các bạn để nó bất cứ đâu ở trong cái
tài liệu cũng được nghĩa là miễn là Ờ Ờ
nó có chế độ là kiểu phải đợi thằng kia
chạy Xong hai là hai phải chạy trước
thằng kia của Vân là được
a
sweet làm Auto Được không anh
ừ ừ
có bạn hỏi mấy cái vụ về auto này chắc
là tự tune những kiểu là tự động làm cái
gì đó thì bạn thân lập trình đó là thế
bất cứ ngôn ngữ lập trình nào Làm được
mấy cái tự động đúng ạ tự động chạy vân
vân nó thể liên quan vòng lặp này là tự
động chạy đến ngưỡng nào đó chứ Thì
nhưng này không phải một bức nhưng mà
với từ ngôn ngữ thì nó sẽ chạy theo
nhiều ciệc đó ra kéo với ra Swift về TP
là chẳng hạn thì chạy bằng web còn là
nếu mà các bạn học sinh sinh cộng cộng
hai xác thì nó sẽ bằng cái phần mềm các
bạn tạo được cái phần mềm xong rồi mờ nó
chạy lên thay vì chạy chương trình duyệt
là em phê các bạn nói như thế thôi I
À còn vụ auto game này thì ý bạn ấy thì
chắc làm chị là cậu mày chơi game cài
Mấy kế
mấy cái game cầy thì à
Ừ thì các bạn nên dùng bằng những cái
phần mềm dùng bằng Nếu mà bằng phần mềm
thì nó mới can thiệp được vào phần mềm
kia chị web này nó không can thiệp thì
sao phần mềm khác nên là các bạn có thể
cốt bằng xí sát ra ta si xì + + gì đó
tiền bà phần mềm ở sẽ can thiệp vào phần
mềm kia kiểu gì thế
à à
lá cây vụ lai of us ra tôi thì đúng là
có hay để ý với việc lượt xem với cảm
thấy là
tôi tôi thường anh xem cái phân tích tôi
không Thực ra tôi cũng cũng buồn nếu mà
giờ sự mấy ông ít người xem nhưng mà tôi
không
Tôi tôi buồn ấy là buồn cái vụ là cái
lượng người xem nó bị ra bởi vì tôi
nghĩa có thể có nhiều người bị bỏ theo
kiểu nào vào nghe anh này nói chán quá
Thế này là buổi sáng không xem nữa xem
cho tuổi tò mò thì ok bỏ qua nhưng mà xe
máy kêu mặc được thấy thần này sẽ không
Hay chán bỏ thì thế buồn thế nào Tôi
thường ai vào xem đánh giá là kiểu trung
bình của một người xem này kết hợp việc
là
theo theo từng cái kiểu Bụi 1 12 thì cái
lượt xem nó nó tăng giảm như thế nào cho
tôi không quan tâm vì cái Line lắm đây
này sang trái nghĩa gì cả trừ khi mày
ông nghĩ like nhiều ơi kiểu có mỗi có
tâm giống như mới video đấy tầm nhìn
thấy xem thì mấy trăm cái đít like cả đã
nghe nghe tỷ lệ thế nó lại buồn quá à
à à
Ừ cái vụ led với Va hôm trước ở da mình
xin lỗi không trước mình là cốt của cốt
một đoạn và mình không để ý nó nó bị lỗi
mình nói lại cái bộ đầy phát nên là nên
là có bạn thắc mắc ở ở phân chat mà mình
không đấy đấy mình mình nói lại cái vụ
lỗi đấy à
ở trạm xóa hết rồi mai đi nha à
Ở hai đầu tiên mình chạy
thì
các bạn nhớ hôm trước mình dậy bằng phô
không ạ pho này rồi cho y = 1 xong rồi y
nhỏ hơn 10
nó bị y + + tất là y tăng lên 1 mỗi lần
chạy đúng không ạ xong rồi đó của mình
Chấm right i này hôm chưa chạy như thế
này thì nó ra in từ 1 đến 99 Sau đó gì à
khi thiếu gia sư mình điện last ở trong
này
khi Apple đầu tiên thì mình sẽ Giả sử
kết thúc vòng lặp rồi mình cũng đi lại
một phát nữa ở ngoài vòng lạc thì mình
in ra giá trị khi mà kết thúc vòng lặp
rồi thì y nó sẽ ra giá trị bao nhiêu thì
các bạn hãy nó ra 10 Nhưng nếu mình để
lén ở trong này thì các bạn thể là nó
mất sử số 10 đi Tại sao tại sao lại mất
số 10 đi ở đây thì được giải thích
trường hợp này thì đầu tiên đầu tiên thì
tại sao mất ed mà chỗ này nó không bị
lỗi bởi thực ra nó có lỗi thì phải mình
xem thử luôn nhé
ở đây Các bạn thấy nó có lỗi chẳng qua
nó không in ra ở trên màn hình mình
Nhưng mà in và xong con xô không ạ
à à
Các bạn thấy là nó có lỗi theo dạng là
như thế nào lỗi là is not defined tất cả
chưa được khai báo đóng ngoặc nghĩa Các
bạn thấy ra cái khai báo y ở trong vòng
lại khi nó sẽ chỉ tồn tại và sử dụng ở
trong vòng lặp đó ngoại nó không thì thì
nó không nó không ra ngoài được đó ngoại
như nó không hiển thị lỗi trên trình
duyệt như mình đã từng nói đó là tài cái
cái trình duyệt các bạn không ngờ hiển
thị ra cái lỗi gì cả kể cả các bạn thẻ
htl không đúng ngày vân vân ra Swift nó
cũng thế squat với nó sẽ hiển thị lỗi ở
trong cái khi các bạn ấy 12 ở một con xô
các bạn hãy ra lỗi đúng ạ lỗi này là tôi
nó lỗi nhưng mà nó lỗi hộp của dòng cuối
nên là những dòng trên nó vẫn chạy bình
thường dòng cuối đến dòng nào nó lỗi thì
ở dưới nó nó mới không chạy được nữa
ờ ờ
âm thanh tra là đôi khi ở các bạn sẽ
không để ý Giờ Và nó có lỗi không Các
bạn cứ tưởng là Ừ trông như thế này chắc
ạ đi còn đây gì đó đúng là nó có vấn đề
nhưng mà nó không ý thì lỗi các bạn để
biết rồi còn vấn đề gì không ạ Ở đây nó
báo cụ thể tại sai tại dòng nào này sao
giờ 13 đúng ạ
thì xem trường hợp này thì các bạn như
mình hôm trước để mô là các bạn có thể
đẩy cái led vòng một ra ngoài này ta nó
nhận
Đây là một cách có thể bạn để red-y
những ngày trước xong rồi cho y = 1 nhân
này tại lại trang này vẫn được Nghĩa là
còn còn cách nữa đó là các bạn để vay
nha à
anh nghe này nó được và các bạn sẽ nhận
ra đấy đó là khi mà các bạn không có
dòng này như thế này thì cái các bạn
biết được là cái y nếu mà các bạn để như
này các bạn biết được trong trường hợp
này thì cái y này nó sẽ tự động là les
hay làm ra
vì thế các bạn thử trả lời cho mình xem
ạ trong trường hợp mà mình không khai
báo như này thì nó nó tự động khai báo
cho mình đúng không ạ thì trong trường
hợp này nó là les hay là ra nếu mà các
bạn trả lời được câu đấy thì thì sẽ hiểu
được cái ra vài cái led nó khác nhau như
thế nào
ai ngờ có vẻ nhiều bạn chọn 3 hơn công
nghệ và đúng đó là Va chỗ mệt thế các
bạn sẽ hiểu dần về việc nét và như thế
nào bởi vì bây giờ mình khử ví dụ các
bạn luôn ấy Các bạn nhớ vụ vừa nãy Milan
như thế này Nó lỗi đây là không ạ nhưng
bây giờ mình đổi nó va như này nó không
lỗi đó nó chỉ đơn giản thế thôi tất cả
các bạn thấy ra khai bảo nó tự động khai
báo đây khi mà y chưa tồn tại nó sẽ tự
động khai báo hộ mình và nó là tự động
khai báo và ngoại để mà khai bảo vai Dạo
này tức là nó sẽ có thể sử dụng ở ngoài
vòng lặp thay vì chỉ tồn tại trong vòng
lại giống như là les đúng ạ nhưng mà
mình mình đang dạy các bạn ở mọi khi và
mình vẫn sẽ dạy Có bạn là mình sẽ thường
dùng led hơn bởi vì cái led nó có lợi ở
điểm là nó sẽ chỉ được khai báo một lần
hai vì thằng va thì các bạn khai báo đặc
biệt cho Bơ mình thử ví dụ các bạn bè
mình sẽ sự là mình à bảo quản lại đi bây
giờ sự led y = 1000 nay các bạn hãy Ok
trong chuyện này sẽ gì sai cả Thế bây
giờ mình gửi cho rat y bằng hai lại phát
nữa thì trống trường hợp này các bạn
thấy nó bị khai báo 2 lần đúng không ạ
ờ ờ
rõ ràng Cho y bằng bột sau đó thì mình
chỉ cần khám y lại bằng hai Thay vì mình
phải mất công led thêm một lần nữa bạn
sẽ thấy trong trường hợp này nó sẽ báo
lỗi này bởi vì là cái này ra hết pin
declare tất cả đã được khai báo rồi này
đái
thì đưa mình độ nó thành như thế này thì
nó nó mới nhận này con nhưng mà đối với
và ấy thì nó nó lại có thể là kiểu ví đè
lên như thế này đấy các bạn thấy nó ghi
đè như thế này thành ra là cái và khi mà
khai báo nó không tốt nên là bây giờ
thường là lập trình viên lại không sử
dụng về khai báo theo kiểu va nữa trừ
trường hợp mà các bạn 1 khai báo một cái
Biến toàn cục cái Biến toàn cục thơ ca
là mình vẫn sẽ chỉ nói qua về Global
và local
tạm thời là như thế còn khi mà các bạn
học xong OB sau khi mình dậy mình sẽ
giải thích kỹ hơn về cái vụ các bạn sẽ
thấy sự khác biệt rõ rệt giữa hai thằng
này còn bây giờ thì các bạn chỉ thấy
việc là Ok nếu mà khai báo kiểu này thì
dùng được mọi nơi còn nét thì sẽ không
được lặp lại kết hợp việc cả led chỉ sử
dụng ở trong cái hàm này sang hàng khác
thì cái biến nói bị vô tác dụng không ạ
mà tại sao có webcam HP
wired ghi tôi chặn luôn
à à
Ừ để tôi cho ông nào là mốt thì ông ấy
chặn Thôi nhé tôi sẽ cho một ông Nam mốt
Ừ hôm qua mình hôm qua mình có nói
chuyện với
chị nhà chị chứ cũng bị spam ở trên
Facebook Sau đó gì à à
và sau đó thì mình bảo là em bắt đầu nổi
tiếng với bọn rác rồi Kiểu gì trên trang
cá nhân mình để cháu ở Việt Nam mà sau
đó đi Bà Ơi Bà là miễn là nổi tiếng là
được anh cờ thấy phải nổi tiếng thì bọn
bọn nó mới tìm đến đấy à
từ ngày tôi thấy hai ông kia tích cực
những hàng alo cho tặng 2 ông đấy trước
đã
thì thì bây giờ có vẻ cũng bị dính luôn
rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu ông tự xử lý hộ tôi nhé nhưng mà
đừng có xử lý càng người khác nhé Không
phải người khác kiểu dạng nhưng miếu cũ
và bình luận với ông xử lý đâu Tôi làm
Mốt đôi khi cũng bị thế tôi làm mốc thì
tôi
anh cũng cái này thuộc vào buổi học
nhưng tôi xin phép tâm sự một phút rồi
đó là hồi mà tôi tôi vậy tôi làm Mod cho
GTA tiền không vào bao nhiêu lần tôi
ngồi tôi yêu thì tôi cũng thường này mời
bạn đấy vào trong nhóm Sau đó gì
nhưng mà tôi không lạm quyền là khi mà
tôi chia tay rồi tôi không chặn được bọn
đấy thôi Tôi cái kính khung là bạn đấy
con được trong danh sách được ưu tiên
kia tôi chặn bạn đấy bằng nick bình
thường rồi nhưng mà Bởi vì tôi là kiểm
duyệt nên tôi vẫn nhìn thấy nick bạn ấy
được Thế nó mới cay ý đấy Xong rồi Thế
nên là nếu mà Mấy ông Để ý kỹ thì đã có
một khoảng thời gian tôi không làm kiểm
trượt nhóm nữa thứ tự rồi khỏi bàn ban
quản trị bởi vì không nhìn thấy nick bạn
này nữa
ừ ừ
đi làm kiếm tiền sướng gì đâu
a a
Ok nói chung à Thôi tạm quay trở lại bài
học người đi xa quá rồi thì
hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học cái nốt cái
thật nhiều nốt đấy nó kiến thức của bên
lập trình trước khi mà mình thực sự là
mình sẽ
sẽ dùng ra huyết kiểu
ở
chỗ thực sự mình sẽ dùng ra Swift để mà
làm một cái gì đó thì đưa mình sẽ dạy
nốt các bạn với khái niệm để lập trình
là khái niệm về aj làm a a
chung kết đầu tiên thì các bạn nhớ về
các các các kiểu dữ liệu của trong
g-speed mình đừng dậy thì các bạn biết
rồi kiu nè flash này kiểu string này và
thời gian mình chưa dạy qua các bạn về
cái kiểu là kiện buôn lần nữa là kiểu là
chua phone không ạ
Và bây giờ mình sẽ biết thêm được kiểu
này nữa kiểu mặt nóng lạnh mà hẳn là gì
thì thực ra là có hôm có hôm chữ có một
bạn đã hỏi ngay cái câu hỏi đó là em
chạy vòng lặp bể nhập nhiều tên được
không anh
ạ phải như này khi rõ ràng mà bạn ơi cậu
bắt đầu hình dung ra được việc là anh em
bạn đấy muốn nhập ra rất nhiều mực rất
nhiều cái gì đó xong ấy một loạt tất cả
đó ngoài ra chẳng hạn thì rõ ràng là
phải thứ để mà lưu lại một cái danh sách
ngủ giá trị như thế thì nó là nó làm mà
tặng Thế các bạn biết qua về cả lý sát
này cái gì đó thì mình sẽ không đề cập ở
đây mình sẽ chỉ nói qua về mạng thôi
Ờ thì thì mi mình không nói về đối tượng
có sách đâu nhé đối tượng mình sẽ hoàn
toàn là để cho bên chuyên sâu
họp Chuyến sau họp nhưng các bạn sẽ thấy
con thiếu một vài cái cho mình sẽ không
nói
thì cái mảnh nó sẽ là như thế nào Các
bạn cứ hình dung nó như thế này bây giờ
sự là
ý mình muốn nhập một loạt số rồi mình
tất cả số đấy ra cùng một lúc là xử thế
là sử ở đây mình mình hình dung nhá mình
sẽ kiểu dạng như này
nhập số này là đầu tiên phải nằm trong
form nóng bạn luôn 5.com em đừng quên
form thôi nhé
nhập số này mình sẽ có một nghiên phút
này cho number này ở đây sẽ IDM ạ Ai đi
bằng in food số đông ạ ạ
anh
xuống dòng này lần này mình sẽ có thận
hai cái nút đi mình sẽ thay nó là một
tuần là
nhập
và mình sẽ on click là
hàm nhập chẳng hạn như này đó
với cái hàng Nhật này
mình sẽ lấy cái số của đã nhập ở trong
cái input này ta led số bằng đó của mình
Chấm ghét em mình mai đi này tim phút số
này
các bạn nhớ cái vụ mà hôm trước thì đề
phòng các bạn cho nó bắt buộc phải là
số Flash đi bắt buộc phải là số đi không
không Tránh trường hợp với việc lưu lại
nó là
là kiểu chuỗi nhé á
Ừ đúng rồi các đoạn này chị anh Pha Việt
một tí thực ra mình đang dậy các bạn nó
hơi bị pha một tí rồi vì à Mình vừa muốn
nhớ các bạn nhớ là các từ khóa tiếng Anh
nhưng mà
anh bởi vì mình đang dạy các bạn thì có
vài bạn bị yếu bị mất kiểu không mất
khóc Mất gốc tiếng Anh có kiểu bạn bị
điều tiếng Anh có
mấy cái bạn mà kiểu isle còn hơn của
mình sông còn bắt lỗi mình phát âm sai
mình sẽ bỏ qua mấy bạn thấy cái nhà Thực
sự thì mình đang cũng dạy các bạn nó có
tiếng Việt nhiều như mạnh những cái từ
khóa kiểu như thế này thì mình vẫn sẽ
phải để nó là tiếng Anh thôi ông ạ
nhưng các bạn sẽ thế thôi bị nửa nạc nửa
mỡ Ông Tý còn về sau nếu mà các bạn muốn
chuyên nghiệp thì đúng là nên để hết
bằng tiếng Anh không phải là
bị mất gốc đầu mà phải để tiếng Anh để
cho cậu Đọc cốt dễ đúng ạ
Mình sẽ ra sự mình sẽ muốn kiểu như này
mình sẽ nhập với cái gì đó ấn vào nhập
thì nó sẽ truyền nó sẽ lấy được cái số
lấy Sau đó Lisa nó sẽ truyền vào trong
một cái mà thì nó sẽ truyền vào trong
một cái mạnh rồi rồi Mình muốn làm theo
kiểu công cái nút nữa là nút y
danh sách đã nhập vào này
tiểu tưởng như này
Ừ
thì mình muốn là cứ cứ nhập gì này là sử
mình bấm Nhật đấy số ngồi nhập như thế
này thôi Bấm nhập cơ thể có thể thế đó
ngọn xong rồi mình ăn In danh sách đã
nhập thì hiển thị tất cả đây thì làm như
thế nào đúng thì như mình nói là mình
một đẩy cái số này
chi phí cho một cái ma đầu nhọn
thì nó sẽ là mình sẽ có ra sự mình có
ghét mà bằng thế này chả này
kia sẽ cái cái này biểu tượng của mảnh
nhé hoặc mua 10 thử qua mạng này
ừ ừ
Em hãy tôi kiểu để cho nó to lên một tí
trong mấy ông dễ nhìn nhé Mấy ông dùng
cả điện thoại em ạ Đây nói như thế này
sau đó thì mình muốn đẩy nó cho Mạnh thì
có Push như thế này sống A thì nó sẽ
hiểu lại cái này hàm của nó đó là màn
này tên của mạ này rồi chấm
a
post là đẩy nó vào và truyền cái giá trị
vào như thế này là chuyện được rồi
đó sau đó thì ra sự là với cái Hà mà Hà
Min ra cả
đó khi bấm và Hà Min ra nó sẽ chạy in ra
email cái gì mình đi rahma nó không ạ
thì mình giờ sự đó comment
chấm dai và sự thế in cả cái mạnh ra như
thế này nhưng mà như mình vừa nãy có nói
đó là nếu mà cậu ngày ế sẽ chắn mảnh lại
không tồn tại đây mình thử cho bạn xem
nhé ạ
anh không Nay mình ấn ơi inspect này ăn
con show Rồi các bạn xem có lỗi gì không
nhé
Anh không có lỗi gì cả nhưng bấm vào đây
thì nó có lỗi cứ làm mẹ không tồn tại
Đông ạ bây rõ là các bạn khai báo mạng
led nó ở trong này nhưng mình vừa nãy
nói nếu mà các bạn khai báo mà ở trong
cái hàng này mà dùng lath thì nó sẽ hiểu
lại cái biến này nó chỉ tồn tại ở trong
này thôi nó không tồn tại ở
khi mà kết thúc cài phông trình này thì
cái mảnh này biến anh không tồn tại
nhưng sao này không giá trị gì cả các
bạn để ra đi chẳng ạ
thử lại nhé
em nói vẫn không tồn tại luôn tại sao
tại sao như thế bởi vì thực sự thì cái
khai báo biến này các bạn chuẩn đã các
bạn khai báo ở ngoài cùng như thế này nó
mới ở krobell nó Nó là kiểu để mà dùng
được cả ở bên này Và cả ở bên này chỉ có
bạn sẽ báo ngoài cùng ngay đến lúc đầu
có trước trước khi có cả hại trước khi
chạy Hải Phòng chừng này nó có ngoài như
thế này
đi đái cây cây nhưng mà trong trường hợp
này thì có bạn dùng led 23 đều được nhé
hai mình thử đi
anh ta
khi đó đúng
Ừ nhưng mà như mình đã từng nói mình
không nên dùng đo của mình like rồi đấy
nó sẽ xóa luôn cả tương là cũ của mình
để mình sẽ có một cái đít ở dưới này
mình sẽ có ai đi là kết quả đi đúng ạ
Sao mình sẽ in vào trong cái đít vậy
thôi họ sẽ là The Last Element
by ID này
và kết quả này chấm nhtm là chẳng hạn
đối ngoại bảng mà những ai
nhập vào này
một này
23 này ăn i này đó các bạn sẽ thấy nói
in ra kiểu ngay đúng không ạ Thế là được
rồi
ngọn thế tương đối được rồi nhưng mà
muốn làm cho nó xịn xịn hơn một tí các
bạn thứ nhất là các bạn thấy đó là do sự
mình không muốn i nó bảng dự dấu phẩy
thế này mình muốn in từng từng giá trị
một ở trong mặt cách nhau bởi dấu xuống
dòng để ạ đúng không ạ
Ừ
đấy thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào thì ở
đây ở đây Các bạn thấy thư ca khi mà
dùng ra Suite và Iran mạnh như này mặc
định nó sẽ nối với nhau bởi giấu súng
dòng đây mình sẽ cho các bạn xem nhé Anh
có solo chấm lót thì mình sẽ thử in cái
mảnh này ở trong cái con solo lót này
thì các bạn hình dung này à
thế
này sợ ni này các bạn thấy là nó sẽ có 2
phần tự và đương nhiên là phân tử nó sẽ
nó Các bạn thấy không ấy mua từ đây là
gì Cái bên này nó gọi là Index họ chỉ
mục của nó gọi kia cũng được nghĩa làm
chỉ là
ma cây ít mạnh các bạn nghe khái niệm vụ
là mạng bắt đầu từ không rồi chị ạ nghĩa
là khi mà truyền số truyền giá trị vào
nó sẽ mặc định Có cái intact có cái kia
là bắt đầu đến từ không như này và nó sẽ
gán giá trị làm giờ từng giá trị cho
từng cái số này một và đương nhiên số
này sẽ tăng dần nó không bắt đầu từ âm
một cái gì cả
A và lúc mà có bạn in ra như này thì nó
sẽ in lần lượt từng giá trị 1 theo đúng
thứ tự và cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy
ý và thận chưa có bạn hệ in ra Ví dụ Lại
in ra thằng ở vị trí đầu tiên thôi chẳng
lại thì các bạn sẽ ghi cảm ngay đó là
kiểu dùng mặt vuông sau đó thì kết hợp
với ci2 Index của nó nhèo dạng ngay
đây ấn nhầm này mình có thể nhập rất rất
nhiều số
ca nhạc
Nhớ mình chỉ muốn in ra số đầu tiên bây
giờ kiểu nó số tiền ấn vào thì nó sẽ in
oslo tiền thôi cho tôi rõ ràng Ở đây có
3 cái đúng ạ Đấy có leo bằng 3 thế là nó
sẽ độ dài bằng 3 đúng không ạ cho nó sẽ
chỉ là một nếu mà các bạn làm cái kiểu
như này
nhưng mà bây giờ bây giờ mới kết hợp với
việc là bây giờ giả sự là mình muốn mình
muốn in có bao nhiêu thằng thì mình sẽ
in bẫy như thẳng và kế Thôi việc là mình
sẽ
in nó cách nhau bởi dấu dầu hoa
anh
xuống dòng rồi như vừa nãy mình nói thì
sẽ có 2 cách cách đầu tiên ấy thì nó sẽ
nó sẽ làm theo kiểu như thế này
cả các tổ tiên mà hồi mà mình mới đi học
đấy thì nó sẽ làm theo kiểu nó hơi bị dị
một ví đây mình sẽ Khái niệm và đầu tiên
mình sẽ cho một cái chuối bằng trống như
này
chuỗi Tại sợ bằng chống Nga số tiếp theo
mình cho vòng lặp for mình sẽ có led
thường hay class II bằng thông như thế
này để mà mình khai báo y ở trong vòng
là mày thôi Khi mà kết thúc vòng làm mày
thì cái nó bị biến mất mình không sử
dụng đi nữa đi này Hôm trước có bạn bảo
nói đấy mà chính là nó là chưa Thế sau
đó thì mình sẽ có nhỏ hơn mà Trần led
như thế này thì tại sao phải nhỏ khuyến
mãi chấm nem về các bạn thấy ạ
Mình muốn in từng phần tử của mảng ra sự
vừa nãy mình có 3 số mình sẽ đi lần lượt
3 số đấy đúng ạ thì tức lạ mình sẽ cho y
bằng không này đi chạy từ không mà đúng
không ạ sau đó thì nhỏ hơn cái độ dài
của mạc và sự là độ dài của mạnh bằng ba
thằng ạ thì bản chất là mình sẽ in 012
thôi mình không yêu mình số 3 bởi vì ạ
Như mình đã nói mà nó sẽ bắt đầu từ
không và nó sẽ đương nhiên nó sẽ kết
thúc bằng tuyệt độ dài bằng 3 những thực
là nó kích thích đến số 2 nó kết thúc
rồi cái này ra là nó sẽ chỉ cần nhỏ hơn
ơi nó không nhỏ hơn 1 bằng ở đây bài y
tự động tăng đấy + + tăng lần lượt này ạ
sau đó thì ở đây mình sẽ có chuỗi
ở
bài Chuỗi cộng bằng để dán tiếp với cái
mạng tại tại vị trí chữ y như thế này
sau đó thì mình sẽ in cả cái chỗ này ra
nó sẽ như thế này à anh
mạnh chỗ này ạ
Em thử lại nha Một này 23
i10 Đà Nẵng
Em soạn Eden đó các bạn thấy nó sẽ nó sẽ
nối với nhau rồi im lần lượt ra đúng ạ
Các bạn hãy nói về nhà và lần này nó
không có dấu phẩy nữa bởi vì đây là
chuyện Giàn là lúc đầu chuỗi này xong
rồi nối từng từng giá trị 1 của cái mảnh
đấy Tại mình sẽ có solo chấm lốp
Ừ
cái mạnh để cho bạn dễ hình dung nhé
số
một này một này hay nghe trở lại này các
bạn thấy nó có
44 độ dài 40 ạ Đấy thì trong trường hợp
này thì nó sẽ là kiểu
để cộng nối từng giá trị này với nhau và
in tất cả ra đường như các bạn thấy
trường hợp này hơi bị rồi Ông Tý vì nó
không cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy không ạ à
Nó có bạn nói qua mình về cái vụ này cái
này bản chất là cái này viết tắt nó là
bản chất nó là chỗ ấy cũ cộng với mặt Dạ
cộng và giá trị của mặt sau đó thì nó sẽ
bằng
Ừ cái cái chỗ mới sẽ bằng chỗ cũ + như
thế này thì viết tắt nó sẽ làm như thế
này cái gì được viết tắt này mình quên
là khi các bạn nó nó có thể viết tắt
theo cửa lại trừ bằng số ngồi nhân bằng
chia bằng như thế
đều được thậm chí phần trăm bằng và phần
trăm bạn cũng được vì nhớ Thế
chả qua nói viết tắt theo kiểu là nó sẽ
bằng giá trị cũ cộng hay trừ với cái giá
trị mới gì đó nó nó cũng đã nào rộng cái
+ + + + này thì ra là nó là kiểu tăng
lên 1 y + + tức là y = y + 1 đóng ngoặc
Hôm trước có bạn hỏi luôn cả vụ cộng y
như thế này nó vẫn nhận nó cũng bằng
y cộng 1 thôi ạ nhưng mà hai thằng này
nó khác gì nhau
ờ ờ
hai thằng này nó khác gì nhau cái vụ này
thì nó liên quan đến việc lại in ra giá
trị
một cái thì nó sẽ là cộng cộng rồi bị
trả về cái i mới còn một cái là trả về y
cũ sau đó thì mới + + đây mình sẽ thử
cho các bạn xem nhanh qua vụ đấy là sự
mình đây có độ đó của mình
Chấm right
y + + như này nghĩa là mình tạm Ân hết
đoạn này đi các bạn dễ hình dung nhé ạ
Ừ thì nó đi pha led tivi bằng không biết
gì
ơi các bạn hãy nói là số 1 Hà do số
không đúng ạ thì tất ở đây sẽ sạc nghĩa
là rõ ràng y ở đây mình tăng rồi nhưng
mà nói in ra cái giá trị của
từ trước khi băng nóng ạ bây giờ sự mình
đổi nó thành cộng cũng các bạn sẽ thấy
là
nó ngược lại thôi Nó làm chỉ là nó trả
với giá trị mới của y
ừ
đúng đấy thì các bạn thấy à trong trường
hợp này của mình thì da mình không quan
tâm giá trị trước đây sau kiểu gì y nó
cũng sẽ tan thôi mình không có tâm nhưng
mà trong một vài trường hợp cả các bạn
muốn trả về giá trị Y Sau đó hãy đi
trước đó Gì đó các bạn quan tâm thôi
ông ạ Đấy nói quà các bạn thì dung về
cái + + hệ - nó thấy nhá Các bạn có biết
cả vụ - thì bản chất nó - 1 thôi ông
xuống công cộng nó bị ngược lại thôi
Ok nhưng mà bây giờ trong trưởng này
nhưng mình lúc đầu mình có nói đó trong
chiều còn này mình muốn in ra cái mấy số
này cách nhau bởi dấu xuống dòng đúng
không ạ thì mình muốn chỉ đơn giản là
xuống dòng ở trong HTML là gì nó là thẻ
PR đúng thì mình sẽ cộng một cái chuỗi
như thế này về rồi nha À
xe tải thì các bạn thể bắt buộc nó thẻ
được bọn nó sẽ như thế này để mình thử
nhé
ừ ừ
ở đó sẽ như thế nào ạ Tại nó sẽ in ra
theo kiểu PR xuống dòng như này à
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là ờ cái kiểu như
thế này là kiểu mà mình cho người dùng
nhập vào một cái gì đó nhập vào một danh
sách thì đó rồi mình I lại toàn bộ danh
sách đề đó thì nó sẽ làm như thế này
ngoài ra là các bạn muốn kiểu in toàn bộ
số
à The Voice ôm kia chửi bậy đó
anh
ở một tin cho toàn bộ số chẵn này toàn
bộ số lẻ gì đó
thì các bạn sẽ khi mà
Ừ ừ bạn kia có
cô
bạn kia có nói vụ chữ a Bike home
hôm nay mình quên chưa chở ba nhà thì
nhắc mình mình mình trao mình trả lời
nốt Rồi mấy vụ này rồi tí mình chữabài
nhá Ok ờ
thì các bạn muốn tin ra toàn bộ số chẵn
hay số lẻ thì nó sẽ như nào đó sẽ là
kiểu mình sẽ chỉ cần kiểm tra xem tại
cái vị trí từ y này nó là số lần số chẵn
hay số lẻ để mà chuyền chuỗi và để in ra
thôi Giả sử là bây giờ mình đang I này
ít nó hết hết này nếu mà trong trường
hợp này mình sẽ sự mình có mạng tại Vị -
phần trăm hay bằng bằng không thế này
tức là nó sẽ chia chia hai lần dư đúng ạ
đã chia hai lệ dư và dư không tất cả
chẳng dư gì cả nóng bọn tớ là nó sẽ Chỗ
trạm Tại mình sẽ được truyền vào trong
nhìn này em ạ
một này 3 này bố này đi Này các bạn thấy
mỗi số 4 thôi Bởi vì à Mình chỉ có
truyền vào truyền vào chuỗi tiệm ảnh
màng thì các bạn thấy là nó có truyền có
bao nhiêu thì nói chuyện bấy nhiêu vào
trong mạng nhưng mà lần này mình in ra
chỉ những những số chẵn ở trong cái mạng
này nó mì in ra đúng không ạ Nó sẽ kiểu
như này
thì các bạn mốt có vẻ làm việc có vẻ
hiệu quả phết
à à
ờ ờ đấy bây vừa rồi Mình hẹn nó qua các
bạn thêm lại vụ là kiểu nhập vào nhiều
sau đó thì dùng vòng lặp in ra từng phần
tử của Mạnh vân vân thì từ đây các bạn
sẽ làm được những bài tập giống như là
bài đây mình sẽ chỉ qua các bạn phải các
bài tập
khi các bạn làm ở không chơi hiểu về
mạng thì chắc là các bạn xem máy video
nhé vì mình nghĩa mình dậy thấy nó cũng
tưng tưng tưng tâm nổi đủ biết qua về
mạng đấy ạ
ờ ờ
vi phạm 1 input này lấy giá trị input
nhập về truyền vào trong mùa mạng này
xong rồi E toàn bộ số chẵn số lẻ của mạ
đấy này in ra tổng số phân tử của Mạc
tất cả nó sẽ in ra + + ngọn tất cả thẳng
với nhau rồi in ra kết quả này số tìm số
lớn nhất số nhỏ nhất này chả nặng thế
Cái này chắc là bài tập các bạn thử về
làm Nếu mà bạn nào mà không hiểu thì cho
bộ xong mình sẽ chữa không ạ Đây là các
số nguyên tố trong mạng nữa rằng lại ạ
ở
bài này sao là để để mình sẽ cho các bạn
làm mà cả bài này nữa bài Thực ra nó
phức tạp hơn một tí bà này liên quan
việc là no mình mình nhập số nhập số
phần tử
em làm mưa dạng ấn ấn phát sinh nó sẽ bị
nó sẽ tự động sinh ra khỏi mạng gồm 10
phần tử hãy kiểu thế cho nó tự động tự
động hiển thị ra kiểu số lớn nhất là gì
số lần nhất là gì tổng là gì chẳng hạn
tại kiểu Như Lai
ý
thì cái vụ này thì thực ra thì cái khó
đấy các bạn thấy việc là nó tự động phát
sinh ra thì mình sẽ trả lời các bạn với
câu này còn mấy cái dưới thì cả các bạn
sẽ tự chạy vòng lặp giữa tự tự tìm hiểu
vụ dùng vàng lập để mà lấy được số lớn
nhất hai số nhỏ nhất thứ thứ
à à
thứ hai tôi có để mua cho mày không hết
nhỉ free mua cho bé uống hết thì sợ mày
ông hết sư bài tập phải làm gì
à à tiện đây nói qua vụ thả mấy ông muốn
cậu chắc là mấy ông vừa nãy khó chịu
giống như tôi là cậu cứ Điền ăn nhập này
xong là lại phải xóa này đi ông ạ thì có
cách để mà nó tự động xóa hộ mình để
mình sẽ có đâu comment like
và lung Nhưng hãy bằng chấm này thì tức
là nó xóa đi cái nó gán vào lu cho cái
cụ cái input này trở lại bằng chấm thì
nó sẽ là xóa đi thôi nha đó nghe rất
tiện ông ạ in ra nó sẽ như thế nào ạ
à à
Em đang định làm gì nhé hà đông ngoài
phát sinh ra mạng không ạ Chứ mình lại
tạm Xóa đi ừ
đi xóa lại đi Này con trường hợp này
mình sẽ là phát sinh đi
này à
Khi phát sinh Yama chọn lại
đây sẽ là nhập số phân tử của mạng à
Ừ
anh thế này
input số số này trong trường hợp này thì
mình sẽ cần phát sinh ra được ấn mạnh
thì nó sẽ làm như sau họ
Ừ nó nó nó là bản chất nào theo kiểu này
mình sẽ tạo ra một cái mạng mới sau đó
thì nó sẽ có mình sẽ truyền rất nhiều
phần tử và trong đó một cách ngẫu nhiên
để tạo ra được một cái mạnh đúng bằng số
hơn tử mình nhập vào nhờ đơn nhiên trong
trường hợp này thì các bạn nên để Thậm
chí các bạn phải kiểm tra xem nhập số
phân tử vào không bắt buộc phải là số 2
không được phép âm gì gì đó thì bọn nó
ổn hơn không ạ
khi hát live show fifo mình còn chưa
biết crippled cả phí khô
khi sex
khi sex Vì mình chưa biết khái niệm về
lắm hoặc cả mình Mình biết rồi Nhưng mà
mình chưa đọc
ừ ừ
A tại mình tí mình tắt là nhịn cô tung
lên một tí cho rõ Này à
Em à đừng quên mất ờ ờ
cái vụ foot phút là đẩy đẩy 7 giá trị
vào trong cái mạng ấy thì như bạn kia
vừa nói thì nó là gì
vì nó là đẩy vào cuối không phải đầy vào
đây
a rest in first-out và first I love our
đúng không ạ
oke viết tắt làm tôi quên mất
cái cái vụ đẩy Phút Vào mà ngoại Futsal
ở Đông ạ khi nó là đẩy quá cuối
27 vào cuối được chị ạ và
anh vào để lấy ra khi mà lấy ra ấy thực
ah lấy ra có hàm giống như Hà đã pop
à nó sẽ lấy sàng đầu đầu tiên ở lại hòa
rằng á
khu đô đối với cái mảnh của đối với cái
mảnh da Swift bị thì thử ca nó nó không
không có thêu kiểu đặt
có thằng nào sẽ thằng ao có tự thứ mà
thực A có hàng để lấy thằng đầu tiên có
thẳng Hà mày lấy thằng cuối cùng nên là
cái việc thằng thằng nào vào đầu với
thằng nào vào cuối thì nó chẳng quan
trọng
à mình mình nghị mình nghĩa là cái đoạn
này bạn hơi bị nhầm cái vụ tách với câu
còn còn lấy việc là mình chỉ giải thích
về vụ pastillas Tất cả hiểu nó sẽ đẩy
vào cuối còn các bạn muốn đẩy vào đầu
trở ra nó có cách để đẩy vào đâu Đây
mình thử nhé bút
em có hàng mà nó thì bạn Ghost ô
first address with chẳng hạn thì nó là
hàm ăn shit này thôi nó sẽ đẩy vào đầu
của cái mặt tức lắm chị ạ nó không quan
trọng với việc là
thằng nào thằng nào vợ thằng nào vào
trước hò và sau mà nó có hàm riêng của
nó để mà đẩy vào trước hay để vào sau
ừ ừ
Ừ cái bút mình là đang đẩy vào cuối cuối
của mặt con việc mà mình muốn lấy nó ra
theo kiểu lấy từ đầu đến cuối từ cuối
đầu thì thì do mình quy định thôi chứ
không không không phải là do cái thằng
Tây nó quy định ở đây nó nó thích hiển
thị ra như nào chị của nó khác với sách
với Kyu ah
Ừ ok ờ
ạ Bây giờ giả sửa Mình muốn lấy số mạ
thì số số phân tử chắc chả nó số nguyên
rồi thì cứ để nói ý Nhớ chắc đi và intro
ngọn tiếp theo
mình muốn ở đây là gì mình sẽ tạo ra một
cái mạng này mình mặc định lúc đầu mạnh
chống này sau đó thì mình sẽ cần là ví
dụ là mình nhập vào số 10 thì mình hiểu
khi bấm vào đây đúng ạ
phát sinh ngoài phát sinh Khi bấm vào
đây thì nó sẽ cần in ra được cái mạc gồm
10 phần 4 đúng ạ Tức là sao nghĩa là cái
mảnh này sẽ được truyền vào 10 lần 10
phần tử này phải mười phần thưởng ngẫu
nhiên không ạ thì mình sẽ khái niệm mà
giả sử mình chạy vòng là pho đã ạ Mình
sẽ có lúc đầu y rat y = 0 vẫn đều không
này sau đó thì y nhỏ hơn
từ nhỏ hơn cái ạ số số này nhé số vốn từ
mình sẽ truyền Bà không ạ Mà ích công
cộng này
xong rồi chẳng trường hợp này mình sẽ có
mạng chấm phút là truyền vào trong cái
mạng này mua cái số gì đó một số số này
phải số ngẫu nhiên em ạ thì thì mình sẽ
có khái niệm là random number kiểm tra
thôi random number lesson này nó sẽ có
hàm random cho các bạn đây mình thử cho
bạn xem nhé Nó làm mát chấm random nhớ
má chấm đông thì nó sẽ chị có bao gồm
giữa không với một thôi Đây mình sẽ thử
cho bạn xem này số nó kiểu bị nó bị lẻ
quá nó kiểu phẩy phẩy phẩy mình cho bạn
xem này quấy là sự mình sẽ có đó của
mình Chấm ghét em ming pei kết quả mình
sẽ in kết quả ra thằng ạ
và mạng đi ừ ừ
vì thế bạn sẽ dễ anh Dũng hơn mười chẳng
hạn
Sau đó các bạn thấy à số này phẩy phẩy
nhiều quá đúng không ạ Các bạn muốn số
nó đẹp hơn thì các bạn hãy dùng flow như
thế này số ngồi cận mục để mà lấy được
số random từ 1 đến 10
Ừ đúng ạ Nhưng mà phải nhân 10 nữa nhé
Mà nhân 10 nữa
à Còn cái cộng một này bản chất là nó
chỉ để cho nó ra nung từ 1 đến 10 thay
vì được không nhé 10 thôi em mình cho
các bạn xem thử bạn sẽ giữ dung này đây
thì mình sẽ đặt tên một cái là led số
ngẫu nhiên ở đây
sau đó thì có số ngẫu nhiên bằng cái cục
này
em trong trường hợp này bỏ mình bỏ cái
cộng đi ở lại
em thậm chí ở mình cứ tạm bỏ cái
flow đi để các bạn dễ hình dung xem như
nào thế âm chia paradom này nó tự trong
phạm vi 01 này nhân lên mưa ấy thì nó sẽ
ra thì tưởng như thế này
anh có ngấn 10 ra kiểu nga sau đó đến
mình làm tròn lên này Đó mình làm tròn
lên nó có khái niệm là Flo làm tròn lên
còn à
ở đâu Nằm lo là làm tròn xuống mình bị
bị nhầm tí Flora sàn làm tròn xuống xong
rồi sale là làm tròn lên sẹo là trần nhà
nó làm tròn lên đây làm cho xuống ngôi
đã bị sẽ à Maslow này làm trò lên này
ăn cho xuống nhưng cứ bị nhầm nhầm nhầm
chữ đỡ rồi đó
ta thử ở lại nha
em à Mình đợi Đợi mình tí nữa cấp bị
nhằm lại phải đầy vào đây đúng xin lỗi
vì sao không không không ra
Nam này
khi tiêm bỏ cái này đi thì các bạn thấy
nó đã bị khác một tí rồi Năm này
vì nó có ra được cả số lớn hơn lớn hơn 1
còn ở đây để cho kiểu flow nha để chắc
chắn nó nó sẽ chỉ ra được những số
thế này này nè Một là không hay là một
hạn luôn như này à
Anh hỏi này cái này có thể ra không ấy
trong trường hợp này nó có thể ra không
đấy do mà chờ ở đây nó cộng như một chất
sắt nó ra một chứ nó không ra không nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ đúng rồi các bạn biết xem cả khái
niệm về rau nữa
rau thì nó sẽ làm tròn theo kiểu là nếu
mà nhỏ hơn 0,5 thì phải thì nó sẽ làm
tròn xuống còn lớn hơn hoặc bằng 0,5 thì
sẽ làm tròn lên cái kiểu như thế ra cũng
được
cái này được không quan trọng lắm mở cửa
là các bạn thích theo kiểu dạng nào thôi
đúng không ạ Nếu mà các bạn như ở trong
bài toán ở đây là nếu mà trong bài toán
ở đây nhá Nó là phân tử sẽ có giá trị từ
0 đến 20 - ạ thì các bạn không nên cộng
thêm số một tấm bia của đây với cộng số
một này nó sẽ chắc chắn là sẽ luôn nằm
trong phạm vi từ 1 cho đến mười gì đó
muốn lên 20 chỉ ngắn nhân ngày 20 thôi
ông ạ
ý là như này nó sẽ không nó sẽ bao gồm
cậu không này bởi vì mình không cộng lên
1 và nó sẽ hiểu giới hạn từ 0 đến 20 về
chưa À tiếp theo là
anh Minh ngã
Ừ mình đang làm gì á
em lấy số nhỏ nhất lấy số lớn nhất đúng
các dịch vụ lấy số nhỏ nhất lấy số lớn
nhất Chắc là Thôi mình cứ chữa cho các
bạn đi bởi vì có bạn chưa học phải suy
thì chả chưa biết để phụ vụ kiểu tạo một
biến tạm thôi
Nói chung là ở đây có vụ mảng này để lấy
được số ngẫu nhiên rồi không ạ ra sự là
bây giờ mình muốn lấy số lớn nhất hai
nhỏ nhất của cái mảnh này thì mình sẽ
làm như sau
mình sẽ
ừ ừ
xu hướng dẫn ra đu không trùng nhá Ờ
Ừ cái đấy thì chắc là mình sẽ nốt mình
sẽ đây coffee
thì mình sẽ nốt lại và nó biến thành câu
sao nhé
không trúng
nãy các bạn hỏi nó sẽ biến thành câu sau
buổi sau mình trả lời nhé Ok
ờ ờ
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ cần mình có một cái
mảnh có một loạt xuống ngựa để không ạ
bây giờ trong trường hợp này mình cần
lấy ra sửa mình muốn in khổ lớn nhất của
cái mảnh đây mình một tin cho cả cái
mạnh và bao gồm cả số lớn nhất của mạng
đấy thì như thế nào luôn á thì rất là
mình duyệt lại mạnh một lần nữa xong nó
thì mình sẽ làm mình kiểm tra lần lượt
từng hàng một ví dụ trong trường hợp này
Các bạn nhìn thấy trong trường hợp này
số nó ít thì còn nhìn được ngay số là số
lớn nhất Nhưng mà nếu là sự kiếm ảnh này
có tận 1 tỷ 2 1000 cái các bạn sự không
không sẽ không kiểm tra được xem số ở số
gần nhất đúng ạ thì các bạn sẽ phải làm
lần lượt như thế nào các bạn sẽ đầu tiên
Các bạn thấy số này được quan So sánh số
này về số này không ạ sau đó các bạn so
sánh số này Số này có rảnh anh xuống này
số này đúng ạ nhưng mà đây Bởi vì số lớn
nhất ngay từ đầu là nó đầu như này ra xử
mình như này thì nào mình ra sự như này
đi dạo Ừ nếu mà nếu là số 9 số 17 số 9
nhỏ hơn 17 rồi thì thực ra các bạn không
cần phải so sánh số 9 và số 15 làm gì
nữa mà các bạn sẽ phải lấy số 17 So sánh
nó với các số còn lại đúng ạ Để kiểm tra
xem số 17 phải số lớn nhất không Bởi vì
chắc chắn chín nhỏ hơn 17 rồi thì các
bạn chỉ cần lớn như vậy thôi không cần
lấy chí nữa đúng không ạ thì các bạn sẽ
hình dung bài toán thì việc là các bạn
đầu tiên các bạn sẽ lấy số đầu này số
kiểm tra nó với số tiếp theo này xong
rồi Nếu mà số tiếp theo mà lớn hơn số
đấy thì sẽ cho số tiếp theo đấy kiểm tra
số còn lại đúng không ạ chúng phải ngược
lại ví dụ Giả sử 17 với 15 thì 17 lớn
hơn 15 rồi thì mình không cần lấy 15 So
sánh 16 nữa mà phải lấy 17 So sánh 16
Đông ạ Hết tức là đây là mình sẽ tạo một
cái biến một cái số lớn nhấ và sau đó
thì mình dễ cho số lớn nhất để so sánh
với lần lượt hàng còn lại mình sẽ tạo
Đây là số lớn nhất đấy
như này đúng ạ thường là mình hay làm đó
là mình sẽ
mình sẽ là mình sẽ cho thằng số lớn nhất
mặc định lúc đầu sẽ bảo thằng đầu tiên
đi cháu sẽ sau đó thì mình mới kiểm tra
xem nó lần lượt với những hàng tiết heo
thì ở dễ nhất mình sẽ có lại led đi bằng
11 vì sẽ những hàng tiếp theo này đúng ạ
sau đó thì y nhỏ hơn
khi mà mạng chấm len là chuẩn
mạng trở lên thì ra là chuẩn nhất đấy ạ
anh
nghe chẳng qua ở trong trường hợp này
mạng chậm leo nó bằng luôn cái số nhập
vào đây là mình có thể ra nó bằng số như
mình cứ để nó ra mạnh chúng đem đi cho
chồng bố vệ của pháp chuẩn đi
vào đây mình kiểm tra à là nếu mà số lớn
nhất nhỏ hơn cái mạng tại vị trí đội y
này thì số lớn nhất bằng mạng tại vị trí
tùy thôi nhưng ai
đó so vơ trong trường hợp này thì tôi
muốn in ra đây là mình sẽ
Em in ra theo kiểu như này đi cộng với
cái chuỗi là số lớn nhất là hai chấm như
này cộng với số lớn nhất
thử nhé Nam này ở đó
là 5 phát nữa cứ cái chạy như này các
bạn sẽ hình dung được thôi đúng không ạ
Ừ
Ok chị ạ
em có bạn kia bảo dùng luôn hàm sau Phạm
Trần rồi lấy thằng đầu tiên thì ra đấy
là một mẹo nhanh thôi mình có thể dùng
hàm mắt của của mạng là luôn cũng được
nhưng mà mình đang muốn dạy các bạn về
vòng lặp và muốn hình dung các bạn việc
lại cái này cũng là một thuật toán đây
cũng là một thuật toán đấy có nhiều thật
có các bạn sẽ phải biết qua một vài
thuật toán
thì các bạn có thể không cần viết tên
của cái thuật toàn đấy là gì Giống như
vậy Giờ mình quên sự tên rồi nhưng mà
cái này để các bạn hình dung được việc
duyệt từng phần tự trong mạng bàng hoàng
lọc hay như nào đấy thường vào bằng bằng
lặp for là đơn giản nhất đấy
Ừ thì các bạn từ ngữ này Thực ra các bạn
lấy được số ống nhỏ nhất thì nó tương tự
thôi giàu đảo ngược lại được
thận chưa các bạn muốn in mảnh theo thứ
tự giảm dần cũng cũng được nó sẽ phức
tạp hơn một tí Vân Vân Vân à
Anh nói xuống đấy có những bài tập này
mình sẽ cho các bạn làm nhỉ Có nhiều Bái
rất nhiều fan thì mình sẽ hướng dẫn cấp
mình sẽ cho các bạn làm dần các bạn hình
dung được các thứ
Em à bây giờ chữa bài nhỉ bây giờ đến
giờ chữa bài nhé à
Ừ đúng rồi bụng ông nào mà chưa hợp qua
suy chưa học qua lập trình thì đúng hôm
hôm nay nhìn cái đống mạng là thấy
choáng nó kiến thức mới dồi sự kết hợp
việc là cơ sở kết hợp lọc với cách mạng
nữa mình nghĩ là nó hơi bị quá tải do
những bạn mới đấy ạ Ừ nếu mà
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự thì
ông nào cũng từng trải qua rồi mà đúng
không ạ Ông là tổng hợp được chị trạng
từng trải qua chán cái vụ này thôi em
mới nghĩ à Làm nhiều sẽ quen thôi
ở
trường mình dậy Cái gì đầu tiên chương
mình hồi cấp 3 mình được học Pascal đã
mình đã biết qua về những cái cẩu về
vòng lặp lại nó thứ thứ tiếp theo cái
thứ rồi đấy mình mình từng kể qua là
mình còn là cái Hằng mà làm bài tập hết
cho cả lớp mà ừ
Ừ nếu như mà hồi đấy mình không Ban Mê
lập trình lắm đâu Họ Pascal đấy không
phải là khiến mình đam mê lập trình đâu
chẳng qua là mình kiểu
Hồi đấy Mình mình ngồi máy tính nhiều ấy
hơn những bạn ở lớp thành ra là kiểu
mình cảm thấy không bị bỡ ngỡ với máy
tính ở một định gõ mày nhanh hơn xong
rồi mình cho mình có vẻ mình
không ngại dùng máy tính hơn không không
ngại học kiểu thế nếu ông kia rồi Ngồi
ngồi làm mảnh wed còn ngại rượu mấy ông
ấy bị lưỡi này ra ở cậu thế nên tôi
khuyên Thì ông chơi game nhiều và chơi
game nhiều được ra mày không còn không
bị lại dùng máy tính à
ờ ờ
để tôi chữa cho mấy ông Thực ra là mấy
ông để kỹ về cái vụ
ít nhất là nhập bao nhiêu số này
là số nguyên tố
I Bet do sự mình để kiểm tra xem số đấy
là số nguyên tố hay không ấy thì
ừ ừ
bộ đề kiểm tra xem một số phải số nguyên
tối không ạ thì mình chữa lần lượt nhé
à à
chị đã sửa lấy số ngẫu nhiên này
cách
kiểm tra số nguyên tố ảnh
đẹp kiểm tra đi
nhập số
kiểm tra sẽ là số
Cái lấy để kiểm tra số nguyên tố x ra
các bạn tra trên mạng thuật toán này nó
ra luôn à
ở mình thường hay làm kiểm tra số nguyên
tố thì mình của lâu lắm rồi mà không
động kể cái đấy Mình sẽ chạy hai hoàng
lạp để kiểm tra gì vậy để thường thường
mình sẽ làm như thế này thường mình sẽ
là
ờ ờ
Ừ thế nào là số nguyên tố đã số nguyên
tố
là chỉ chia hết cho 2 và Trí nó đúng
không ạ
không ạ ạ ạ
đề thi thì mình một là mình sẽ làm một
cái biến đến
mình là lúc đầu cho biết đến chia hết
bằng không Ngay sau đó thì mình chạy
vòng lặp
kiểm tra từ số 1 tới số đó
ví dụ ở số ví dụ số đó là 5 lần thì tất
cả
12345 đúng không ạ cho mình kiểm tra lần
lượt là một số số số năm là này có chết
trong 120 trong trường hợp này có chia
hết được ngọn thì đếm chưa hết nó tăng
cộng cho tăng lên là một ông ạ sau đó đi
kiểm tra đến hai xem chưa hết 200 đúng
không ạ thì bên đấy mà vẫn là 13 như thế
vẫn là 14 như thể là một vẫn một thôi
chế cho 50 ạ thì bên để mà sẽ tăng nghe
hay không ở cùng khi mà cái điểm chưa
hết này nó bằng bằng 2 tin tức là sao tự
đã số này số nguyên tố để cái cơ bản
nhất
à Anh nhầm 19 nó Mình bị nhầm
nhầm nhầm gõ nhầm đấy chứ Chứ tôi nói
đúng mà đúng không ạ bây giờ xử số 6 rồi
Dao số 6 thì các bạn thấy sẽ chắn nó
phải số nguyên tố đúng không ạ bởi vì
một Nó chết hết này cộng lên này hay lắm
Chết này cộng tiếp này ba nó cũng chết
này cậu liên tiếp và 40 trên hết nhưng
mà nó vẫn là ba rồi Nam con chế và ba
rồi và sáu nó lại chia hết là tăng ấy 42
ra là không phải là số nguyên tố không ạ
Có số 2 thì đương nhiên là bạn khi bão
số 2 hoặc số 2 số nguyên tối thôi Một
chia hết tăng lên này hay chết cũng tăng
ơi này đúng không ạ Đấy cái này là cái
gọi không chung các bạn nói rồi nó là mã
giả nghĩa mình đang nói thì kiểu lại lý
thuyết trước như thế này sau đó thì mình
bắt đầu người sáng cốt được ạ Mình sẽ có
tạo một cái biến đến lúc ạ
bộ
đếm mình sẽ led để em chưa hết
bạn không sau đó thì mình sẽ chạy từ 1
cho đến số đấy ông ạ
ba đến số đáy bằng luôn muộn đi tăng dần
này sau đó thì mình kiểm tra ít
số đấy phần trăm cho cái vị trí lũ y = =
0 Tức là chưa hết này đồng loại mình sẽ
cho Đếm chưa hết tăng ngoại sau đó thì
mình có một cái biến kết quả đấy được
biển kết quạt
ở đây lúc biến kết quả như này như thế
này sau đó thì ở đây mình sẽ ít Đếm chưa
hết
bằng bằng hai đúng ạ thì mình sẽ cho kết
quả là
đúng
còn đây ngược lại thì kết quả sẽ là sai
và ở đây mình sẽ chị in cái biến kết quả
thôi à
trò chơi thử nhé
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ ok chưa Thế thôi
Ừ đúng rồi có bạn ở kia trong trường hợp
là một cách cũng rất là hay Có rất nhiều
mẹo nhanh để làm cái vụ này tôi từng
nghĩ về gần mấy cái mẹo nhanh của vụ này
cái này cái cơ bản nhất có bản nhất thôi
mấy ông có thể chơi theo mẹo theo kiểu
lại
chạy bắt đầu từ số ba này
sau đó thì
nói chung có nhiều cách mà nhưng mà tôi
tôi nghĩ à mày ông
lên mạng tra bên cái thuật toán lấy số
nguyên tố nó cũng ra cái này chỉ là nó
qua để các bạn Hình dung là việc là chạy
vòng lọc để xử lý một cái gì đó thôi tôi
không vậy mấy ông về tối ưu 10 cái này
lắm
Ừ đấy Ở đây là in từ 1 đến số đó thì cho
mày không biết rồi Từ sổ đỏ đến số 1 Nếu
là số âm đều ra mấy ông
chỉ cần ít theo của đoạn vòng lặp for để
mày nó ra thôi
nhập enter để nhập thay vì Ấn nút này từ
ra có bạn trả lời ở đây này
Ở đây có bạn lắng nghe cái sự kiện là
khi mà cây áp Hoặc gây đau tức là khi
bấm cái nút ở trên bàn phím ý nếu mà Rồi
các bạn biết về vụ khi cốt trước à án
chị là mới ra Suite nó luôn quy ước cái
phím ở trên bàn phím nó có cái cốt của
nó là số và mình kiểm tra xem số đấy nó
bạn 13 chỉ tất cả thì mentor II
thì các bạn có thể có hạn của chàng để
biết được
Ông Bà mình mình đang gõ cái kia cốt là
số nhiều này sợ mình lên tôi sẽ ra 13
này
em gái mình có chữa thì nó ra thì cốt là
600 Điện ảnh cái gì đó như thế này mình
gõ bất kỳ cái cái gì chả qua bấm chuột
được không Được rồi dầu cách nào cũng ra
này đấy
à à
khi con cún của mình nó vẫn chưa quen ở
ngoài mà ờ ờ
à À đúng rồi hôm trước tôi bảo mấy ông
có thể lên kể giống tôi để bạn muốn học
cách dạy chó thì mấy ông nên cái trang
lại boss slot này từng nói quay để anh
này Anh ấy giải thích có vẻ rất là ôi là
mà tôi đủ kiên nhẫn dạy con đấy thường
là tôi sẽ vuốt nó nếu mà không biết dậy
được có hư quá nhớ thật nhưng hợp nhưng
mà anh ấy nói có vẻ hả cậu nói chung là
bạn chắc là nó chó rất là trung thành và
nó kiên trì kiên nhẫn mình phải kiên
nhẫn hơn nó Anh ấy nói với hai cái kiểu
thì phải kiên nhẫn hơn nó thì mình mới
dậy rồi nó chứ Mình có phải mất bình
tĩnh mình có mình nói nó thì cho nó cũng
sẽ nó theo cậu Trung Thành nhưng ở nó
giống như là mấy ông Khi mà yêu ai đó
một cái mũ quán thôi họ có trà Đạt tấm
lòng ông thế nào nữa thì ông sẽ vậy đuôi
vây đuôi mỗi khi mà họ kiểu thả thích
không hay gì khó thôi đến em à
Vì thế nên là mình đánh nó xong rồi gặp
lỗi chẳng biết gì cả họ cũng sẽ với đua
nhưng nó vẫn sẽ hiểu cụ yêu thương mình
củ nhưng mà nó luôn có suy nghĩ là muốn
làm điều gì đó tốt cho mình thành ra là
cậu mình phải biết cách dạy cho nó việc
là thế nào là tốt cho mình đó ngoãn chứ
không phải cứ đánh nó Đánh nó thì nó
không nó cũng không hiểu là mình đang
ghét hay là đang rượu khó chịu khi nó
làm gì đó lâu nó còn cứ nghĩ là mình
đang xả tức vào nó và nó sẽ làm chịu
đựng điều đấy
thế nhưng mấy ông khi mày yêu ai đó vậy
nếu không biết thực ra cái từ si tình
Đức à Ngu si Đồ ngu không biết giơ mua
thì ca si tình nữa thằng ngu đấy nhỉ Đấy
à
Ê mày cũng không biết nữa bây giờ mình
không biết rồi Thế nên mỗi khi mà bảo là
mình si tình có thứ thì ra nó nó ngu đấy
Ok bây giờ tranh thủ chia sẻ nốt về mấy
cái thì hôm nay mình lại nói qua về một
tí về cái kopan
Ừ tí mình để một lát Minh ở ở bình luận
của cái video nhé À kết Copa mình đã
từng chia sẻ rồi như bây giờ mình chỉ
chạy thêm một vài cái cốt nó khá hay và
màu kết hợp với cả ra quyết này Ờ Cái
cái này là tự động gợi tự động đề xuất
khi mình gõ một gì đó sẽ gọi cho ai lại
các bạn thấy nó đề xuất ngay cả đầy kĩ
là thứ là cái chữ này lấy từ đâu Cái gợi
ý này lấy từ đâu lấy từ cái mạng có sẵn
này cho nó sẽ gợi ý ra ngay hay phết 1
là bấm vào đây nó ra được luôn chữ này
hay mình Tab và cái nó xảy ra luôn chữ
này thì cái để làm thế thì nó toàn bộ và
Switch rất là ngon tiếp theo này cái này
Thực ra là không phải ra sweep cái này
chị ăn dạng ở dùng CS khi mà Harvard vào
nó hiển thị lên nhỏ trong đẹp này em ạ
Đợi tí rồi phải Linh nghỉ tí gửi mấy ông
tiếp này cái này là một trong hồi hồi mà
copan khối cũi nó có cha thôi còn là tìm
kiếm những cái kẹt ten cái này các em
nhé tệp cái tên ngon
được nhiều người thích nhất thì thì
cái cái vụ bây giờ tìm kiếm nó không
không có cái đấy Hơi bị cay nhưng mà may
mà tôi lưu và này hồi trước rồi cái là
cái mà hồi trước được được thích nhất
này Nó là sao
à Mà ông thấy hiểu nhất là nóng Tìm kiếm
tất cả những từ lặp lại và và nó lặp lại
bao nhiêu lần nó sẽ đời xuất đây này và
ông có thể tăng độ dài cho nó lên này
khi tăng độ dài hoặc áo giảm độ dày của
chữ để mâu muốn tìm giờ sự thật chữ có
độ dài là ba thì sẽ có bao nhiêu chữ
được lặp lại ở trong đoạn văn bản này
ông để thay thế đoạn văn bản này bằng
bức tượng mà nó không muốn nhé và nó sẽ
để nó sẽ hiển thị ra được chữ lặp lại và
đương nhiên cốc cả này toàn bộ bằng
g-suite Thế các bạn sẽ thấy à rất là
ngon
a tiếp theo nữa Cái này là do diện ổn
này giao diện này tôi chia sẻ thế thôi
mấy ông mình con Coffee Về đồ án của mấy
ông giao diện được có giống hệt nhau thì
có được như này nhá Đấy cái này da xịn
này ấn vào đây hiệu ứng cái thứ mấy
Em đẹp mà đúng không Đẹp vãi chưởng
anh bị ông thầy có hiệu ứng kiểu nó loa
lên như thế này tha thứ mà mày không
biết ngay nó bằng giá Speed đấy
anh béo hấn view in Exciter để làm mấy
ông xem kĩ xem cố tỏ gì rồi nhé
Ừ ok
đứng ở thử ta là mình không Mình không
quan tâm lại việc mấy cái hình ảnh lại
về sau mình sửa nó thành kiểu sản phẩm
của mình mà không ạ Cái này nữa cũng rất
là ổn này cái này mày không thấy hiệu
ứng các thứ thế này trong đẹp vãi
anh Đại Nghĩa lúc đầu ông sẽ có sẽ
refashion có có nhân này cái sẽ có trận
đấu không ạ
ở tại sau đó thì mày Ông bấm vào đây này
nó chọn một cái đấy xóa cái hát em ở Cái
dưới đi Xong rồi thì chị ra ở đây cái
hiệu ứng rất là màu mè không ạ Đấy cái
thứ thứ ra Switch Plus này là có canxi
Kali để mà Viết cốt cho nó tiện hơn thôi
cho tôi chỉ đang nói cho mấy ông về việc
ra sức có thể làm được những gì nhé
có
ai Ví dụ ở cái này nữa Cái này giao diện
nhưng mà nó là ra Speed vậy các bạn sẽ
thấy là đây nó Los lên như thế này nó ra
Swift này
Ừ nó lót lên như thế xem lại hiệu ứng
nhé đó lót lên như thế là ra Speed có
bảo rồi cái gì nó chuyển động kiểu dáng
ở Nga sẽ ra switch
em gái con cái này nữa Cái này giữa ngon
Hồi đấy còn được cho các chỉnh sửa cái
phát xít rồi cơ em bây giờ nó bị đóng
rồi
Hồi đấy à
Ai Cập nhật cái file Google sheet này
Ai Cập nhật cái gì thì lập tức cái Menu
này là thay đổi cái bản chất cái Menu
này dùng ra Switch nó sẽ gọi đến cái
đừng dẫn này để mà lấy ra giá trị ở trên
Google sheet bản chất Google sheet thừa
nó cũng làm một cái kiểu dẫn các bạn vừa
học với nó nó cái mảnh thôi Nó là mạng
mạng lấy giá trị về xong rồi in cái toàn
bộ danh sách cái giá trị lấy ra đúng
loạn đấy nó sẽ in ra như thế này
ơi các bạn hãy thấy da Asus làm được và
bất kỳ ngôn ngữ lập trình nào tôi đã
cũng làm được chính Google sheet này
chính Giả sử ông có phái xem đúng không
Nhưng mà ông có file Excel có sẵn tất cả
các danh mục các thứ ở những có ông của
Nina theo dõi tim lời cho chồng mà đẹp
đúng không Chỉ làm Thế còn lại không ạ
rỡ ngủ
em nó đỏ vừa rồi tôi nói quai bị những
cái tác dụng của dress with Nhưng mà
mình sẽ không học những cái đề được đâu
bởi những cái đến những cái mồm mè Vì sẽ
học những cái gì thì tôi đã nói qua về
vụ là đến cuối của cái
cái buổi g-suite này bạn mình cần phải
biết làm cái hoa Tết là để kiểm tra kiểm
tra cái việc nhập dữ liệu và đầu mạnh
trong cái phone mình sẽ kiểm tra xem
nhập dữ liệu vào đúng hay sai các sự để
ông có thể đọc qua của virus clip trước
cũng được mà thôi cứ là dưỡng học lên
dần dọn mềm bở tra cũng muộn rồi tí thôi
đưa mày ông bài tập này không thử xem
Làm được không em ạ
tự
làm thức là cũng giống như bạn Đỗ Sinh
kia chẳng ạ Mấy ông tranh thủ cũng á đề
thi thoảng vào lớp xem và các bạn khá
sản ở nhà tôi thấy mấy ông là do diện
các thứ trả lời được câu sao cho mẹ ổn
phết
Ừ nhưng mà đấy là số ít mình khẳng định
luôn đấy có thể số ít thôi còn như bạn
vẫn có thể vẫn đang không theo được thì
các bạn có thể xem bài tập người ta đúng
không ạ ấn concho để mà xem suốt người
ta cốt như thế nào Cứ để mình tham khảo
bỏ qua giao diện đi Mình xem cốt người
ta như thế nào tham khảo và cũng để góp
ý luôn đó là sự mới làm gì đó xấu đây
làm gì sai
học hỏi từ bạn bè vẫn đang nhanh nhất mà
không ạ
Thôi chả buổi hôm nay thế thôi Tại sao
bây giờ lại lượt xem đông thế Chứng tỏ
là mấy ông không học hành thì mấy ông
chỉ vào xem cuối giờ tôi chia sẻ gì rồi
đúng không
lễ hội Chào mấy ông nhé
Ừ ok
ừ ừ